foreign  [Music]  this is space High a cluster of urban  villages in Shanghai it's home to  thousands of low-income migrant workers  who come to work in the wealthy  Financial Hub but can't afford to live  near the city center  to maximize rental income many landlords  in these Villages divide their houses  into tiny units causing problems with  sanitation and safety during the  lockdown in Shanghai earlier this year  the entire became one of the coronavirus  hotspots where hundreds possibly  thousands of people were sent to  quarantine  Shanghai has been demolishing  neighborhoods like this for years to  make room for new development projects  but now migrants are facing renewed  threats of eviction because the  potential for Kobe outbreaks is driving  authorities to speed up the process  while landlords usually get compensated  migrant workers affected will have no  choice but to move further away  this raises the potential for social  backlash or even unrest  [Music]